federal agents are going after employers
who may be using illegal workers these
unannounced visits are yielding big
results and as you can imagine big
complaints to fox business network
correspondent hilary vaughn is here
tonight with the story US Immigration
and Customs Enforcement agents are
targeting businesses more than ever in
2018 the assistant director of Homeland
Security Investigations Matthew Allen
says they have a directive straight from
the president to ramp up worksite
enforcement operations like this one
where they catch businesses completely
off-guard and audit every worker on the
payroll if you are not paying attention
to your your workforce and making sure
that you have a lawful and legal
workforce you should be concerned that
HSI could show up on your doorstep
that's not healthy for business Allen
says audits like these are now a
lynchpin in their strategy to crack down
on illegal immigration because it works
in 2017 HSI conducted about 1,700 audits
of companies I think you can expect us
to almost quadruple that this year last
year HSI collected over 97 million
dollars in assets and fines from
companies that violated federal labor
laws one of those companies paid fifteen
million dollars to the federal
government the biggest fine ever levied
from one of these audits Allen says
these totals could hit new highs in 2018
but it's not just ice that's turning up
the heat on employers new California
laws are putting businesses in the
middle of a political fight with DC
threatening thousands of dollars in
fines if companies cooperate with agents
without seeing a signed warrant first
and that sparked confusion among some
California businesses if somebody's just
show up and knocked a door but if that's
the law if there's the compliance I have
no no ideas what to do but Allen says
while sanctuary city laws may try to
shield illegal immigrants from
deportation employers aren't off the
hook no employer should believe that
they have any protection or safe harbor
from HSI worksite enforcement program
they operate a business in what they or
anybody else interprets to be a
sanctuary city Alan tells me a lot of
tips HSI gets are actually from business
owners themselves who are ratting out
their competition for cheating the
system he says they're trying to level
the playing field Bretton interesting
Hilary thank you